l'expression avoir une vie de chien vous
connaissez et ben moi j'avais la pire
qu'ils soient riches et puis c'est selon
moi la même couleur de poils j'ai dit
pas de chien et quand je dis non c'est
non je vais l'appeler ville il est clair
c'est important nous on voulait
absolument que ce soit un vrai chien ça
nous a pas du tout et flore et d'esprit
de faire un chien en images de synthèse
c'est un vrai côté c'est un vrai coach
aimé mais ça n'est pas du tout
antinomique avec ce cri les chiens dans
la bd on doit à peu près contacter 200
personnes pour trouver le bon caractère
parce qu'en fait le secret de ce métier
c'est d'avoir le bon chien qui
correspond à 2 par son image et de par
son ses capacités intellectuelles ou
physiques à réaliser ce qu'on attend le
travail de manu lui adressions avec le
chien moi je trouve ce que j'ai vu je
trouve que ça tient du miracle c'est à
dire que le clebs déjà il joue bien
en plus il est hyper cinégénique c'est
là une bonne gueule quoi on peut avoir
de l'empathie pour ce chien comme comme
on peut en avoir pour un accord et en
plus il fait ce qu'on lui demande
en fait il des caves de faire beaucoup
de choses mais pas forcément ce qu'on
s'imagine en tant qu'humain quoi c'est
vraiment obtenir ce qu un animal frais
naturellement dans la vraie vie d'une
famille mais l'obtenir sur commande quoi
vous avez dit que voulait pas prendre de
chiens tous ces [ __ ] entre douch la
lady que vous n'auriez pas vivant